IT IS GOING TO PROBABLY INVOLVE
A STATE-BY-STATE STRATEGY AS
THEY GO, SO AGAIN, THIS IS AN
EVOLVING KIND OF COUNTER
CAMPAIGN TO WHAT THE SUPREME
COURT DID, IT KIND OF STARTS
HERE TODAY.
BACK TO YOU.
>>> THANKS, BRIAN.
SO, TESLA FOUNDER, ELON MUSK
HAS TOLD TWITTER HE WANTS OUT
OF THE $44 BILLION DEAL TO BUY
THE COMPANY.
>> IN A REGULATORY FILING
RELEASED YESTERDAY, A LAWYER
ACCUSED TWITTER OF BREACHING
MULTIPLE PROVISIONS OF THE
ORIGINAL DEAL, WHICH WAS SIGNED
BACK IN APRIL.
FOR MORE ON THIS, HERE WITH US
NOW, IS CNN'S CHIEF MEDIA
CORRESPONDENT, BRIAN.
BRIAN, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
WHAT ELSE DO WE KNOW ABOUT ELON
MUSK'S REVERSAL HERE?
>> WE KNOW THIS IS SETTING UP A
MASSIVE LEGAL BATTLE BUT  HE
HAS LOTS OF LAWYERS ON HIS
SIDE, AND TWITTER PROBABLY JUST
HAS JUST AS MANY.
THERE HAVE BEEN SEVERAL MONTHS
SINCE HE AGREED TO BY TWITTER,
HE WAS OFFERING A VERY HIGH
PRICE, MUCH HIGHER THAN ANY
OTHER, ANYONE ELSE IN THE
MARKETPLACE, AND NOW, THERE IS
AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE FUTURE OF
TWITTER BECAUSE HE SEEMS TO BE
TRYING TO BACK OUT.
WITH ELON MUSK, YOU NEVER QUITE
KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON FOR SURE,
YOU ALWAYS HAVE TO BE
SKEPTICAL, THAT IS WHY MANY
PEOPLE WERE SKEPTICAL ABOUT
THIS DEAL WHEN IT WAS FIRST
ANNOUNCED, I THINK NOW THERE IS
SKEPTICISM ABOUT WHETHER HE CAN
GET OUT OF THE DEAL, AFTER ALL,
WHEN YOU AGREE TO BUY A COMPANY
OVER $44 BILLION, IT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT YOU JUST WRITE
DOWN IN PENCIL, YOU HAVE SIGNED
IT IN INK, YOU HAVE DONE A LOT
OF DIFFERENT THINGS, TO COMMIT
TO ACTUALLY GOING THROUGH WITH
THE TRANSACTION.
HE IS TRYING TO GET OUT OF IT
BY SAYING THAT TWITTER HAS
BROKEN HIS SIDE OF THE DEAL BY
NOT BEING HONEST ABOUT FAKE
ACCOUNTS, BOTS, AND CONTROLS ON
THE PLATFORM.
BUT, HE HAD LOTS OF TIME FOR
WHAT IS KNOWN AS DUE DILIGENCE
TO THINK ABOUT WHETHER TO BUY
THE COMPANY BEFORE HE AGREED.
SO, WE ARE GOING TO SEE IF HE
CAN GET OUT OF IT OR NOT.
>> THE QUESTION, BRIAN, IS
THERE THAT PORTION OF THE
CONTRACT, WHERE HE COULD BE ON
THE HOOK FOR $1 BILLION, DOES
THAT STILL STAND, WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT?
>> THAT IS RIGHT, A $1 BILLION
BREAKUP FEE IS ONE POSSIBILITY,
BUT TWITTER IS INDICATING THEY
WANT TO HOLD HIM TO THE $44
BILLION, THEY ARE SAYING TO
HIM, SHOW ME THE MONEY.
HERE IS THE TWEET OVERNIGHT
FROM THE BOARD CHAIR, HE SAYS
THE TWITTER BOARD IS COMMITTED
TO CLOSING THE TRANSACTION ON
THE PRICE AND TERMS AGREED UPON
WITH MISTER MUSK AND PLANS TO
PURSUE LEGAL ACTION TO ENFORCE
THE MERGER AGREEMENT.
WE ARE CONFIDENT WE WILL PREVAIL
, THEY BASICALLY SAY WE WILL
SEE YOU IN DELAWARE, WE WILL
SEE YOU IN COURT, YOU BETTER
FORK OVER THE $44 BILLION, WHY
IS TWITTER SAYING THAT?
THEY DON'T SEE ANY OTHER OFFERS
BUT THEY DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
BIDDERS WHO WOULD MATCH HIS
PRICE AND THEY DON'T BELIEVE
THE STOCK IS GOING TO GET IT
BACK UP AS HIGH AS HE IS
OFFERING.
THE TWITTER BOARD, THEY WANT TO
CASH OUT.
THEY BELIEVE THE SHAREHOLDERS
WANT TO CASH OUT AND THEY
BELIEVE HE HAS TO PAY UP.
THIS COULD GO ON FOR MONTHS BUT
MORE LIKELY THIS WOULD GO ON
FOR YEARS IN COURT UNLESS THERE
IS SOME SORT OF AGREEMENT WHERE
HE PAYS A LOWER PRICE AND BUYS
THE PLATFORM, OR DOES PAY THAT
$1 BILLION BREAKUP FEE, BUT
EVEN IF HE PAYS THAT $1 BILLION
BREAKUP FEE, THERE ARE BIG
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE FUTURE O